one of the top Democrats in the House of
Representatives in fact the man who many
thought was going to succeed Nancy
Pelosi as Speaker the house should
Democrats win in the fall lost his
primary last night his Congressman Joe
Crowley he was widely expected to be
House Speaker next year if Democrats
retook the house as we said instead he's
on his way out he was toppled by a
twenty eight-year-old self-identified
socialist called Alexandria Acacio
Cortez during the primary Acacio Cortez
attacked Crowley for his race saying
that as a white man he was not fit to
represent the district she explicitly
said the election was quote about race
can you say things like that now
apparently you can and win charlie hurt
his opinion editor at The Washington
Times and he joins us Charlie I didn't
grow up in a there always been bigots in
the country for sure but you see people
running for office saying don't vote for
the other guy because of his skin color
when did that become allowed and why
didn't nobody say anything about it no
it's absolutely staggering and and
you're right it is something that you
would never you would never hear anybody
in decent company say but increasingly
it's been something that that is
accepted on a front you know coming from
the left and you know ever since the
beginning of the whole Tea Party
movement we've been we've been sort of
waiting for a similar reckoning to hit
the Democratic Party and I think that's
what we're saying now and all along the
question has been how bad would it be
and what you know you look at some of
these candidates that Republicans put up
the tea party candidates they weren't
the best candidates they were a little
rough around the edges but at the end of
the day they were constitutional lists
like Mike Lee may be annoying but but
they loved the country these people are
communists and that's a real problem and
and Democrats are gonna have to contend
with this and this is not going to be
the last sitting Democrat who is going
to get ousted by some socialists who
wants free stuff for everybody that
comes out of nowhere this candidate in
Queens ran explicitly against Isis and
called for a South Africa style truth
and reconciliation
commissioned to go through the sins of
ice it's human rights abuses you're
going to see other Democrats run on that
platform oh I think absolutely and I
think that you will even see and this is
the coddling that we saw from the
Democratic leadership going on years now
we're gonna start seeing actual
mainstream Democrats in Congress pushing
this lie about ice and my goodness what
do you expect when they talk about
things that when they accuse ice agents
and Border Patrol agents of being like
Nazis I mean my goodness what do you
expect is gonna happen with some of your
candidates I mean I'm having look I
don't wanna make I know that Politico
just two days ago said that Crowley was
a shoo-in it was an automatic win I mean
people didn't see this coming even the
so-called experts so I don't want to
pretend that I know where the electorate
is on everything but it doesn't seem to
me that if you ran in a general election
on abolishing a law enforcement agency
that protects our borders you could win
could you win on that no and I think
that you know who knows New York 14 may
be this sort of candidate can win there
but I can guarantee you anywhere else
across the country you're not going to
be able to win on this and all of this
plays right is the hands of Donald Trump
I would argue that Donald Trump got
himself reelected this week and it's
because of crazy stuff like this and the
Maxine water stuff and and and and the
hanging people in public it's it's all
playing into Trump's hands it sure seems
that way